una caída en desgracia para la socialité
británica que alguna vez se código con
personas como el príncipe andrés y
donald trump en diciembre del año pasado
chrysler y maxwell fue condenada por
cinco de los seis cargos que pesaban
contra ella el más grave tráfico sexual
de menores
un jurado unánime ha declarado aguirre y
maxwell culpable de uno de los peores
crímenes imaginables facilitar y
participar en el abuso sexual de niños
crímenes que cometió con su socio y co
conspirador de muchos años jeffrey
epstein el camino hacia la justicia ha
sido demasiado largo pero hoy se ha
hecho justicia
los fiscales describieron la conducta de
maxwell como escandalosamente
depredadora dijeron que ella era la
clave del esquema de epstein para atraer
a las jóvenes muchas de las mujeres que
acusaron al multimillonario de abuso
dijeron que maxwell había servido como
intermediaria preparándolas para el
abuso para estas mujeres el juicio fue
una oportunidad de cierre después de que
epstein se suicidara mientras esperaba
el juicio maxwell que ahora tiene 60
años niega haber abusado de nadie y dice
que está siendo el chivo expiatorio de
los crímenes de epstein